Một báo cá mê gì, tên để phương là tin ô đã mạnh lên khi độ bộ vọt của bất miền Trung phí liên,
mang theo gió rật hơn 200 kỳ mẹ mưa giờ và mưa lớn.
Bộ cơ quan khi tượng nước này phải sẽ hạc nè gió at đi mạc.
Như tình thuật quần đạo V-sa yас đã được nặt trong mức cạnh mạo cấp 2,
mức cao thứ 2 trong thang cạnh mạo của phí liên.
Cơ quan khi tượng nước này và gà xa trụ biết,
báo cá mê gì có sức gió vý trì một chân nó mùi kỳ mẹ mưa giờ,
dật tới 200 lệ nằm của mẹ mưa giờ.
Và sẽ dí truyền của khu vực biệt xa yас trước khi giả biển đông và ngày 16 mồn.
Bà gà xa cạnh báo, báo cá mê gì có thể xuy giống nhẹ khi đi qua địa hình đồn đối của phí liên,
nhưng bân giữ cường độ bảo mạnh trong xuất hành trình.
Hơn một chăm sóm mưa trên bài đến và đi từ các khu vực biển hưởng đã bị hoạt vi.
Trong khi các tạo viên được yêu cầu cấp cạnh an toàn.
Giờ trước phí liên cạnh báo, báo có thể khi nước gập cao hơn 3 mẹ tả nhiều khu vực viên 2 mian Trung.
Các mê gì là cân báo mạnh thứ 2, tần công phí liên trong vòng 2 tháng qua sau xíu báo ra ra ra ra ra hủy tháng chiến.
Từng khiến miền bắt lưu dông, tên liệt bi mưa lượng và giỏi mạnh.
Các mê gì giữ kiến đồ bộ vào Việt Nam, ngày 1 bài tâm miền 1.